[Music]
so
[Music]
there's an old native american proverb
that says
inside every person there are two bears
forever locked in combat for your soul
one bear is all things good compassion
love trust the other
is all things evil fear
shame and self-destruction
what's happening
don't let go of my head
what's happening here
hide here i have to go help them
no no please don't leave me alone
danny i have to go back stay here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
it's up to us no it's hunting donny
why danny because that's what she fears
come on help
take danny to a safe place and i'll take
care of this bear
[Music]
what are you going to do i'm going to
play with them
get the rap of you
are you crazy that thing will kill you
he's right it's magic
no italy
what's the last thing you remember danny
he said we had to run
the reason you survived is because
you're a very
uncommon girl
you're not alone not anymore
do you know what mutants are
would anyone like to share their first
time
rain i was 13 i thought it was a dream
i just lost control sam
i started panicking people got hurt
roberto my girlfriend her burner
ileana i killed 18 men one
by one
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
[Music]
[Applause]
it's important we find out your power so
we can help you get better
i saw something
i don't think she wanted me to see
[Applause]
i don't think we're here to get better
this place takes your greatest fear
it makes you live through it until it
kills you
who's there
we can get out of this together
[Applause]
[Music]
we are going to tell you about our new
movie the new mutants in just
60 seconds ready go i play danny a young
mutant who wakes up in a sketchy medical
facility run by dr reyes you're not
alone danny danny meets the other young
mutants being monitored there
rayne ileana roberto and sam dr reyes
wants to help them understand their new
powers so they have therapy sessions to
discuss their haunted past
what if i just want to go home sam you
remember what happened
yep therapy
but then things get weird
and they discover that they can't leave
this isn't a hospital
it's a cage as if being trapped in a
creepy hospital isn't horrifying enough
they have to face their fear when a
sinister force invades
you start to question dr ray's motives
you can't live when i say so we're
trapped in here with demons and you want
us to stay trapped
it only gets worse from there
do they get answers go see the new
mutants to find out
get tickets now
[Music]
and your mutants are dangerous
this place takes your greatest fears
the new mutants that'll help a kid sleep
pg-13 get tickets now
you